So what defines a partner?
What's really interesting is that this has to be a 2-way street.
One way we say that is shared economics.
Not only do you have to get something out of the relationship,
but so do they, and so you really need to understand
what's in it for your partner.
A classic start-up mistake is understanding why you need them
but not being able to articulate why it is that they would need you.
They should need you not only for success,
but boy if they don't have you, they should understand that their business might fail.
A partner might also take a form of co-development or co-invention,
or you might share common customers.
But, one of the things to remember is all the books about partnerships
and all the literature you read tend to be about partnerships
of companies the same size.
But you are a tiny speck to most potential partners.
Remember, you're a start-up, and that means they barely could see you,
and so there are some special pitfalls,
some special things to talk about throughout the rest of this presentation.